hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well David Hume is
classified among the in British
imperialist furs oftentimes in the
lineage of Locke and Berkeley and Hume
placed at the end although of course
there were many empiricists after Hume
as well just none quite so famous we
could say and you can see this
empiricism which we're going to talk
about in just a moment showing itself
very clearly at the end of section 2 of
his inquiry concerning human
understanding where he derives a sort of
rule that is you know quite quite
helpful in many cases and is also
emblematic of what it means to be an
empiricist so let's talk first about
what we typically mean when we were
referencing this notion of empiricism it
often gets presented as if you know the
empiricist it what defines him or her is
that they believe that all ideas or all
things within our mind all knowledge is
coming from the outside from experience
of the external world that's not
actually technically correct for n
the empiricists in part because we also
have internal sensations and perceptions
and passions and Hume thinks that those
play a very important role we can have
impressions of our own internal states
like for example getting angry the
feeling of what it's like to be angry or
he's got you know the example of cruelty
or generosity or friendship all of those
sorts of things so we have to widen it
and we have to then say all right it's
experience in general that is the source
of all of the ideas in our mind and
therefore of any knowledge that we have
it has to be if not necessarily of the
external world at least of you know the
external world plus the internal if we
want to call it world or whatever it
happens to be that we are and that's not
bad that's a good way to understand
empiricism but we can also talk about an
empiricist project why insist so much on
this well because as we see with Hume as
we've also seen with other thinkers
before him there is a sense in which
empiricism is going to clarify things
that people have been all mixed up about
in the past and so Hume is using this to
target unclear ideas that correspond
primarily he thinks just to terms and
he's using this to attack what we might
call abstractions that people engage in
and deal with if it was today we might
think in terms of ideologies or
stereotypes or all sorts of things along
those lines in his time he's talking
about philosophical terms that people
use without having a clear idea about
what it is that these these terms refer
to and so we can think of them Pyrrhus
ism is not merely an assertion about
where our ideas and therefore our
knowledge comes from but also as an
insistence that we apply a rule that at
least
in some cases says well where are these
ideas coming from show me the experience
or experiences from which you're
deriving this or what you're talking
about
probably is not really the case as a
matter of fact it might not even be real
ideas that you're working with they may
just be as you know Plato back in the
theaetetus called certain conceptions
wind eggs you know sort of miscarriages
of the use of the mind so what does Hume
tell us at the end let's actually look
at the text here he says that here's a
proposition which not only seems in it's
so simple and intelligible but if a
proper use from made of it would render
every dispute equally intelligible and
banish all of that jargon which is so
long taken possession of metaphysical
reasonings and run disgrace upon them so
what we've got here is clearly an agenda
a philosophical agenda to clarify the
things that people are getting into
interminable disputes and discussions
about this is the old you know dream of
philosophy if we could just kick our
ideas and our terms clear everything
would fall into place so he says all
ideas here's a key thing about ideas all
ideas especially abstract ones are
naturally faint and obscure the mind has
but a slender hold on them they are apt
to be confounded with other resembling
ideas and when we have often employed
any term though without a distinct
meaning we are apt to imagine it has a
determinate idea and next to it so we've
got a lot of different components here
in this very short paragraph ideas are
naturally faint and obscure they're not
as strong as impressions so you know
again if we want to use Humes example of
anger it's one thing to feel anger to be
in the situation it's another to talk
about it and when people start talking
about it the ideas sometimes get a
little bit hey
actually a lot hazy according to Hume
they're apt to be confused with similar
ideas in terms of the passions we might
talk about the likelihood of people in
discussions confusing anger with hatred
or confusing anger with indignation or
confusing anger with aggressivity or all
of these other sorts of things right
people often do get into very strange
discussions about these they're they're
apt to be confused with similar ideas if
we're talking about the notion of
physical force
maybe we confuse that with the notion of
our wills as humans going to talk about
later on in this this inquiry as well he
says that this is especially so for
abstract ideas and we ought to think
well what are abstract ideas so you know
simple ideas are that like the yellowish
I guess you could call it goldenrod of
this book combined with the black and
you know all these letters and stuff
like that this book is already a rather
complex thing that you might be looking
at or hearing me describe that yellow is
a simple idea you can look at it and now
try to visualize it in your mind and the
longer you get away from you know
actually having seen it perhaps the
fuzzier it gets and the more confused
it's easy to mix it up with another
yellow or even the white of the chalk on
the chalkboard abstract ideas aren't the
sort of perceptions that we're talking
about here of individual objects or
sensible States instead they're ideas
that we form precisely by taking a bunch
of ideas a bunch of impressed arrived
from impressions and then sort of
distilling out a kind of common essence
to them at least in theory
sometimes abstract ideas might just be
things that we've heard about and have
never actually experienced and we hear
people talking about them and we can't
afford this is where we get into trouble
right
when we use terms as Hume says we
imagine that there is a determinate idea
attached to those terms so there's all
sorts of possible examples of this Hume
talks about you know the idea of like
the the occult properties hidden behind
the phenomena that we're seeing like
those of force or elasticity right we
don't actually know what these are when
it gets when we get down to it or you
know even the conception of the will is
a little bit hazy for us isn't it
I mean it helps when we consider actual
willing when we imagine that there's a
determinant idea just because there's a
word corresponding to it that's when we
run into all sorts of problems and and
difficulties and we might think of you
know countless examples in our own time
in the present think about our entire
virtual world and the ideas that we use
to describe it think about code for
example right code is something that
strictly speaking we only observe tiny
little portions of most of us never look
at any code whatsoever and use things
that rely upon code and we talk about it
as if we actually understand what the
hell we're talking about and we've got
the hazy Ascan ception of what code
might actually consist in and there's
many many different kinds of codes right
we can abstract something out of it and
you know if we want to be really you
know sticklers and they all reduce down
to machine language you know just a
bunch of logic circuits well yeah I
guess so I mean have you ever observed
all those those sorts of things if you
spent a lot of time digging around in
those and looking at them I mean we can
go on and on and on about this sort of
example but that we can multiply many
other examples as well impressions Hume
says are very different they are strong
they're vivid and a key idea that
corresponds to the obscure impressions
are actually distinct from each other he
says
limits between them are more exactly
determined nor is it easy to fall into
any mistake or error with regard to them
so this you know distinction between
impressions and ideas ideas are really
easy to get mixed up especially when
they're abstract especially when we've
got terms floating around that we're
using for them as sort of a substitute
for actually thinking about them
impressions not so much those are the
things we directly experience we can
derive a rule whenever now notice Hume
doesn't say whenever any term he says
whenever a philosophical term is used
without any meaning or idea now we're
gonna have to clarify that a little bit
but just go with me on that we can ask
ourself this following question what
impression is the idea derived from he
says if it's impossible to assign any
this will serve to confirm our
suspicions by bringing ideas in so clear
a light we may reasonably hope to remove
all dispute which may arise concerning
their nature and reality now we should
ask ourselves what would it actually
mean for a philosophical to term to be
used without any meaning whatsoever is
that really possible
is it really possible not to have any
idea attached to it and the answer is
probably no but we could say you know
the meaning or idea is more or less
vague more or less easy to confuse with
others hard to specify and if that's the
case if we can't actually trace it to
some sort of impressions then maybe the
idea really is not something we should
be relying upon let alone saying
corresponds to some sort of reality
right because remember ideas are at best
sort of replicas or representations of
what's supposed to be out there or what
we're directly experiencing in here so
we want to
you know be a little bit careful about
this but we can use it and this is what
the empiricists do over and over again
they'll say alright you get using these
terms over here what do they correspond
to what are you actually talking about
that we can observe in the world and
then turn our attention to or observe in
ourselves and by by introspection turn
our attention to what what do you
actually have in mind and it's not a bad
rule one thing we do have to keep in
mind is that some ideas are in fact
produced by using the imagination as
Hume you know did an example of or
several examples of in the this very
section he says that the creative power
of the mind includes this Faculty of
compounding transposing augmenting
diminishing the materials offered to us
by the senses and experience so you know
in the case of golden mountain you can
actually have an idea of this and it's a
pretty clear idea but you can't find a
golden mountain in reality or virtuous
horse or some of the other things but
for a lot of things that people get into
disputes about like discussions about
freedom or goodness or again code right
or efficiency maybe we want to ask what
impressions what what things out there
in the world or in us that we can
actually point to and share as
experiences what are we actually talking
about here that's how Hume thinks we
ought to proceed when it comes to our
ideas and our impressions in this
empiricist manner
you